[Applause]
scenes of violence and Chaos not far
from the Israeli knesset the country's
Parliament and the political heart of
West Jerusalem and where the highly
controversial bill was passed part of a
larger packet of a proposed judicial
overhaul by Israel's prime minister
Benjamin Netanyahu and its far right
Coalition my mind is incapable of
comprehending anything like that my
heart and my soul are
dreading and scared and and I don't know
what to do
as the bill passed submits protests in
the knesset it also led to a show force
on the streets tens of thousands of
protesters raised their voices some
blocked major highways many were met
with water cannon skunk water and
multiple arrests by Security Forces
protesters are calling it the end of
democracy
[Music]
listen to us because the majority of the
people want democracy law n he says the
bill will bring the power to elected
officials and away from the courts
today we carried out a required
Democratic move the move was aimed at
restoring a degree of balance between
the authorities which was here for 50
years we passed the bill of
reasonableness so the elected government
could lead the policy in accordance with
the decision of the majority of the
country's citizens
Former Defense Minister
anybody who thinks they've won today
will soon find out that this was a real
mistake for everybody the direct person
responsible for that is the prime
minister
this piece of legislation among other
things would strip the Supreme Court
from striking down government decisions
on the basis they are unreasonable
protesters and critics insists who put
the country on a path to autocracy
this evening we've really seen Defiance
on display as Israel faces a Crossroads
of a crisis that only seems to deepen
and also a crushing blow for protesters
who have stood against the bill from the
beginning
Laura Khan Al Jazeera West Jerusalem
Bernard Smith has more now from the
protests in Tel Aviv
they've been protesting here like this
similarly to this for the last 29 weeks
and it's really turned out to be fairly
impotent protest because they've been
protesting against these judicial
reforms and they've lost they've gone
through but people here are very angry
and upset visibly angry some of the
people we've been speaking to because
they fear for Liberal Israel's what they
believe is Israel's democracy this Tel
Aviv is sort of a liberal small island
in the center of a more conservative
country and it's here where the protests
have been LED from well we've also heard
from Benny Gans Former Defense Minister
leader now of the blue and white party
he says the direct responsibility for
everything that's happening now lies
with prime minister Benjamin Netanyahu
says in front of us Bennigan says in
front of us lies a clear and immediate
danger of continuing oppressive
legislation the appointments and the
appointments of political judges and
guns goes on to say that everything
approved here will eventually be
withdrawn from the statute books in
Israel they don't have the majority in
Parliament to stop this legislation
going through but the all the
indications are is they're going to try
and take it to the Supreme Court to have
a judicial review and of course they're
taking to the Supreme Court the very
legislation that will is you going to be
used to diminish the power of the
Supreme Court so when that happens it
probably will happen then you'll have a
constitutional crisis the Supreme Court
being asked to rule on laws that will
reduce their powers there are many
months minimum months of this of this
crisis to continue to evolve into a
constitutional crisis
is a member of the knesset and the
hadash movement he says as long as
there's occupation there will never be
democracy
for more than 50 years now Israel is
being you know and engaging was engaged
is engaged in a in an ongoing
dictatorship a military dictatorship in
the occupied Palestinian territory this
Jerusalem
and Westberg and Gaza Strip which is
which is under the Israeli Siege as we
know so first and foremost Israel is a
dictatorship as far as the Palestinians
in the Occupy territories are concerned
now not
unsurprisingly you know there is a
penetration of the occupation and the
occupation system culture and means into
a Israel proper and now Israel is
turning following this law and it's just
you know at the beginning other laws are
expecting beyond the corner and the
those are going to turn Israel into a
full-fledged fascist dictatorship in
which the most fanatic and a zealot
components are in power yeah I want to
apply to the International Community
it's your responsibility to put a
pressure on the Israeli fascist
government it's up to you to stop the
madness because eventually it's not only
the Palestinians and we in Israel who
are going to pay the price but the
region and the whole world is going to
pay the price it's up to you to stop
them stop them remember what happened in
Europe 19 years ago we are not too far
from there stop it
well the U.S described the passing of
the judicial bill as unfortunate Mike
Hanna has more now from the White House
in recent days the Biden Administration
has expressed deep concern about this
legislation President Biden did so in
person with the Israeli president in a
meeting last week and in a subsequent
phone call with the Israeli Prime
Minister now that the first part of this
legislation has been passed the White
House has issued a statement saying it
regrets that this was done without
consensus saying that consensus is
needed to make effective changes within
a democracy the White House pointing out
that only 64 members of the 120-seat
Crescent voted in favor the opposition
boycotting the vote in protest there's
also an awareness within the Biden
Administration about what is the context
of this act knowing full well that it is
being driven by the far-right
Nationalist Partners in the Netanyahu
government along with the extreme
religious groups they are driving this
and the administration is well aware of
the fact that this is just the first
brick in what is designed to be a wall
of legislation which could result in a
shrinking of democracy within Israel
Mike Hannah altazira at the White House
well David mednikov is an associate
professor of Middle East studies in the
public policy at the University of
Massachusetts Amherst he joins us from
there now welcome to the program in your
view then just how big an internal
crisis is this for Israel how pivotal a
moment
major moment this could be
the beginning of the biggest turning
point in Israeli politics since 1967
which we all know as the beginning of
the occupation of the West Bank at Gaza
Strip the level of
internal conflict among Coastal more
secularized Elite Israelis and the
right-wing nationalists and
ultra-orthodox who are aligned with
Netanyahu is is very very deep you
mentioned this on Yahoo there to what
extent is this fuels do you think my
personal grievances of his I mean after
all he is on has been on trial for
corruption charges
yeah I mean of course it's very tempting
to believe that when a long-standing
leader who is facing criminal charges
um has the opportunity to meddle with
the judicial system that there's there's
certainly a strong incentive I think
more to the point Netanyahu follows what
political scientists like myself
think about as the authoritarian
Playbook and that's where democratically
elected leaders use
um various tactics to erode the checks
on their power and move their country
away from democracy I think this is
something he's been doing for a while
with right-wing nationalism and
certainly these reforms
make it much more likely that he and his
government will have a lot of power
including to quash his own prosecutions
and the bigger picture then how will all
this be viewed by those who support
Israel internationally how uncomfortable
will this be for them
well I can mostly speak of course too of
to the American
situation you know the United States and
Israel have been certainly since the
binding mission on somewhat Divergent
paths in terms of politics and I mean
you just quoted the Biden
administration's
strong concerns about this
um the the bulk of the American Jewish
population tends to be liberal more
secular very much aligned with the
Israelis that are protesting these moves
and younger American Jews and younger
Americans more generally
are really questioning
um the conditions that Palestinians have
lived under for a long time and so you
know in the United States and elsewhere
I think what we see are genuinely
um progressing forces that don't see
things the way the Netanyahu
Administration does and you know even
more
um directly are aghast at these types of
reforms um and this you know applies to
American Jews who have grown up really
supporting Israel for decades it's you
know watching a democracy seem to be
unraveling watching
um what seems like God's law being more
important than the rule of law is very
scary to many Americans and many
American Jews given what you say then
where do the protesters go from here
what will their strategy be now
that's a good question and of course you
know my positionality is somebody
outside of the country I have many
friends that are involved in the
protests I understand that the pressure
is going to continue
um what I think
um I'd like to see in many people who
care about the Palestinian dimension of
this would like to see would be genuine
linkage of the question of Israeli
democracy with the question of
Palestinian rights so that
um there what there could be in fact
common cause around
the danger this represents to both
Palestinians and Israeli liberals so I
think you know trying to broaden the
Coalition keeping the pressure up
um it's clear the pressure matters it's
a moment in which the people really
propelling that the reforms don't want
to back down and don't believe that they
have to back down so I think as an
earlier speaker said you know we're in
for a sustained
um period of political crisis and
um certainly the Israeli opposition is
going to continue to to press as hard as
they can to to walk these reforms back
and maybe to see if you know the
government can can collapse and and
there could be new elections
thank you very much indeed for joining
us here on Al Jazeera
you're very welcome thank you